نواصل الان في استطلاع الموقف داخل قطاع
غزه وينضم الينا الان من غزه محمد ابو
مصبح المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه سيد محمد اهلا بك
تحدث مراسلنا هشام زقوت من رفح قبل قليل
عن ملامح هذا المشهد
الانساني الذي اصبح ربما معروفا لدى
الجميع لكن نريد ان نعرف الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ما الذي تقف و عليه من واقع
انساني على وجه التحديد في غزه
اليوم بالتاكيد اسعد الله صباحكم وصباح
جميع المتابعين عبر قناه الجزيره اليوم هو
اليوم 101 من العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه وهذا الرقم يشبه كثيرا ويرتبط كثيرا
باجهان ابناء قطاع غزه كونه الرقم المجاني
الذي يتواصل من خلاله المصابون والمستغل
الى جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني الرقم
101 بمناسبه هذا اليوم استطعنا بالامس
ادخال عددا من مركبات الاسعاف الى غزه
وشمال غزه ونتواجد الان في محافظه غزه
لنعيد من جديد شريان الحياه الى هاتين
المحافظتين بعد ان اجبرتنا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قصرا لاخلاء مستشفى القدس
وتوقف خدمه الاسعاف والطوارئ في لاكثر من
شهرين في محافظه غزه
وعززنا الطواقم المتواجده ولم تكن ولم تقف
خدماتها في شمال غزه من خلال النقطه
الاسعافيه ومركبه اسعاف واحده الان لدينا
خمسه مركبات اسعاف تستمر في خدمتها بجانب
ابناء شعبنا لا يزال الهلال الاحمر
الفلسين يقدم خدماته الاغاثه وخدماته
الانسانيه في جنوب قطاع غزه للمواطنين
والنازحين تحديدا ولكن الوضع الانساني
كارثي جدا تحديدا في ظل البرد الشديد
والمنخفضات التي لا ترحم حتى رقاقه
ورقه الجدران البلاستيكيه التي تاتوي فيها
وتحتوي فيها عائلات النازحين في جنوب قطاع
غزه الان تتحدث عن تزويد مستشفيات غزه ب
سيارات اسعاف ما الذي يمكن ان يخففه هذا
المعطى من حاجات
متراكمه لدى سكان هذه المناطق تحديدا من
يترددون على المستشفيات
او المصابون جراء القصف
المستمر بالتاكيد نحن ادخلنا مركبات
الاسعاف الى غزه وشمال غزه لتقوم بنقل
المصابين الى المشاكل التي اعيد تشغيلها
بامكانيات بسيطه
وامكانيات تكاد معدومه اما بالنسبه
لمستشفى القدس وعندما زرنا بالامس ايه
مجمع القدس التابع للهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني تفاجانا بحجم الضرر والتدمير
الذي الحقت به قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بل بالعكس بانها قامت باشعال النار وابرام
النار في داخل اقسامه الطبيه واقسام المبي
ليصبح غير مؤهل للتشغيل بجانب اننا سنقوم
بمسانده المستشفيات الموجوده حاليا وتشتغل
بقدرتها البسيطه بمركبات الاسعاف لتكون
مسانده لها واقامه نقاط اسعافيه مسانده
لاستقبال عدد الاصا ولكن اود الاشاره
باننا عندما دخلنا بالامس الى محافظه غزه
كانت البنيه التحتيه مدمره بشكل كامل وان
المنازل جميعها معرض الى رشقات صاروخيه
ورشقات من القذائف الدبابات والتي تزيد من
معاناه الوصول الى اهلنا في غزه وشمال غزه
اكاد باننا اقول باننا سنقبل على مرحله
اكثر تعقيدا في اعاده العمل في محافظتي
غزه والشمال بجانب الضغط الكبير على
مركبات الاسعاف والاطقم الطبيه في جنوب
غزه مستشفى الامل لا يزال صامدا في مدينه
خانيونس يستقبل المصابين ويساند المستشفى
ناصر بمحافظه خانيونس وان عدد النازحين لا
يزال موجود في هذا المكان القابع نقوم
بتقديم العيادات المتنقله لتجمعات
النازحين ايضا في خانيونس ورفح ونامل ان
نستطيع مطابق هذا النشاط في غزه وشمالها
عدد المتطوعين المساندين يزدادون اكثر
بجانب طواقمنا الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
والمسعفون يواجهون تحديات النزوح وتحديات
الفقدان والاستشهاد والانتهاك المباشر كما
ان عدد المسعفون الذين يشاركون معنا في
غزه تركوا ذويهم في جنوب قطاع غزه وابوا
الا ان يشاركوا في استمرار الرساله
الانسانيه ضمن مبادئنا و ضمنا رسالتنا مع
ابناء شعبنا محمد ابو مصبح المتحدث باسم
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه كنت
معنا من غزه شكرا جزيلا